alarme ist luca herzlich willkommen wir
heute meine damen und herren zu ersten
episode von dem untitled bußgeld
ihr habt wahrscheinlich überhaupt keine
ahnung um was es hier gerade geht
das sind wir wir können laufen
wir können auch rennen und wir können
statt an ich komme da nicht rein
da würde ich sagen gehen wir einfach mal
in die andere richtung hier wir können
zum rennen a gedrückt halten das heißt
wir laufen jetzt einfach mal hier lang
und sehen schon zum neigen nach von lte
halten was lte brücke b um den schnabel
zu benutzen also kann ja danke ich weiß
nicht wo ich mit diesem schuljahr
hinlaufen soll nach unten neigen um
dinge vom boden aufzuheben okay was soll
ich denn jetzt mit diesem studium machen
der gast keine ahnung sehr gut steht das
spiel jetzt schon also gut laufen einmal
den weg hier weiter lang bekommen hier
jetzt mittlerweile an ein tor
was soll ich da jetzt eigentlich dieser
dose machen ja dann sehr gut und jetzt
ja ich weiß dass wir dadurch müssen khh
ok jetzt bei gott ja ich weiß wir
brauchen beide way noch einen namen für
diese ganz also falls ihr eine idee
haben sollte wie wir diese ganz hier
nennen sollten das mit sicherheit nicht
schreibt mich auf jeden fall gern mal
namensvorschläge unten in die kommentare
wie ich diese ganze nennen sollen in der
nächsten folge werde ich mir dann einen
davon raussuchen
allerdings müssen wir jetzt irgendwie
hier drüber wir wissen eigentlich schon
wie das game heißt aber danke nochmal
ich will mir jetzt einfach mal zu
anderen seite und gehe hier raus und wir
sehen schon wir sind an einem park
angekommen glaube ich hier vorne ist so
ein wasser ding irgendwie ihr habt hier
vorne liegt ein apfel den kann ich auf
jeden fall nehmen und kann ins wasser
schuss apfel was soll denn deiner
meinung nach jetzt machen also wir sehen
auf jeden fall dass wir vorne so ein typ
steht zum anzeigen der aufgabenliste und
der steuerungselemente bankdrücken okay
also ich kann ich habe aufgaben
leider spielt erich komplex gehe in den
garten ich glaube mit dem garten ist
dieser ort hier gemeint ich habe keine
ahnung wie wir hereinkommen sollen
wir haben hier vorne decke kann ich die
nehmen kannst du den kannst du okay du
bleibst mal da ich habe überhaupt kein
plan b was irgendwie abgeht einmal
schauen der typ ist immer noch nicht auf
uns aufmerksam geworden
dann können wir auch mal diese was ist
das eigentlich
aber ich bitte die musiker der entdeckt
uns gerade und damit herzlich willkommen
zum anteil bei gott der mich gefangen
lauf kleine ganz so kommen aprilia und
zack gehen den garten haben war muss
sich jetzt vor dem verstecken hier kommt
er überhaupt noch wieder
ich glaube er fragt sich wo der andere
sack ist planung wurde er sein könnte
macht den gärtnern us laufen wir mal
hier vorne einfach wieder raus einmal
ich glaube der gärtner tut uns nichts
weil guck mal da macht nix was ist wenn
ich hier
ok dann tritt er mich jetzt auch noch
beruhigt dich ganz wir laufen einfach
mal um den gärtner hier rum
mit ein bisschen abstand weil ich weiß
nicht was da von komischen tanz aufhört
haben hier vorne ist auf jeden fall ein
wasserhahn deswegen kann ich da
theoretisch den man machen
ok jetzt macht er den wieder aus oder
was sehe ich genauso
was was will der typ vor mir ja weg ich
soll den gärten auf jeden fall nass
machen
das heißt ich mir jetzt einfach mal
diese gießkanne und stelle die kann ich
die die gießkanne kann ich die vola ich
musste ich das mache mich stellte gibt
kann einfach mal ein bisschen hier
drunter genau jetzt mal hier das wasser
alles fließt alles schönen die die scala
oder fließt dann eben glaube ich auch
deine ernst was willst du ich verfolge
jetzt mal eine andere idee und zwar der
tüte also übel heißt auch sein radio von
ej lassen doch das radio de da kann ich
dich einmalig das machen ich denke den
gerther jetzt dadurch ab dass hier vorne
das wasser als das verschafft mir
nämlich ein bisschen zeit dass ich mir
hier die gießkanne schnappe genau zack
und die hier schnell runter setzte
genauso und jeder fan machen
nein es geht alles daneben kommen ganz
sie habe nicht so viel zeit ja cool das
ist doch nicht war bisher war ich mache
jetzt eine andere aufgabe
und zwar cloud dem gärtner seine
schlüssel also er hat seine schlüssel
auf jeden fall an seiner linken tasche
kleben
daher versuche ich jetzt einfach ganz
stumpf zu warten bis er stehe aber ein
gott der ist aber auch dass auch immer
in bewegung ist nicht dein ernst denn
jetzt eine kühlbox weg nein schlüssel
fahrer
ich habe die schlüssel vom gärtner sala
den gärtner dazu seinen sonnenhut zu
tragen
das war relativ easy er okay so einfach
ist doch nicht der sonnenhut hängt auf
jeden fall hier oben das heißt ich
könnte
kann ich mir eine treppe bauen was
passiert hier gerade ich will einfach
nur den sonnenhut nehmen kann er den ich
tragen der hängt doch da wird dein sohn
lud den song not man dort nun habe ich
ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung wie ich das
ganze staffel soll von daher will ich
sagen schauen wir mal weiter auf der
aufgabenliste die harke in den teich ich
glaube ich habe eine taktik und zwar
nehme ich das radio und laufe einfach
wieder irgendwo hier vorne hin schmeiße
das radio dementsprechend hierhin der
gärtner müsste jetzt ankommen genau der
wird seinen radio holen und das
verschafft mir die zeit mir hier die
haken mit zunehmendem noch die hakelige
ist um so schnell und jetzt da ich ein
rennen
kl e motor und ich glaube ich hab's
geschafft weil ja das war relativ
unspektakulär ab ich bin hier einfach
hier ein der abführung also haben wir
geschafft machen picknick bring auf die
picknickdecke sandwich apfel kürbis
karotte gemeinde lade thermoskanne radio
koppers wissen dass ein krankes
picknickdecke also das erste was wir
brauchen ist die picknickdecke ich weiß
nicht ob das hier irgendwie im kopf drin
ist
[Musik]
wo ist die picknickdecke
was ja mann ich will nur rumlaufen aus
dem garten raus und schauen uns erst mal
hier anderweitig ein bisschen um mich
meinen wir sind ja noch gar nicht
richtig um gelaufen hier das ist
abgeschlossen
da kommen wir wahrscheinlich dann
nämlich anderen challenges geschafft
haben und was haben wir denn hier vorne
freunde jetzt die picknickdecke das
heißt das ist schon mal der
prädestinierte ort für unser picknick
dementsprechend erhole ich erstmal den
dings hier den apfel genau und wir
bringen den apfel mit unserer ganz hier
vorne zum picknick ja das ist was soll
der apfel jetzt machen april ist auf
jeden fall durchgestrichen das nächste
ist ein sandwich das liegt doch schon
auf der bank aber okay dann schmeißen
wir das sandwich ja auch noch auf die
picknickdecke sms auch durchgestrichen
krippe ist brauchen wir doch aber okay
wenn mister ganz bzw wie auch immer der
name dann schlussendlich sein wird ein
kürbis haben will auch mein gott nein
lass doch arschloch ok
er geht weg das heißt wir können uns den
kürbis nehmen und ganz leise herumlaufen
es nicht wahnsinnig erwehren die kürbis
okay das war einfacher als gedacht dann
nehmen wir jetzt auch hier so eine
karotte mit und bringen auf die karotte
exklusive ganz einfach aus karotte
schmeißen wir vorne und so selbst stecke
er war so blickt nick becker bringt auch
die picknickdecke bleibe aber wir
bleiben alle lade um ein gott ok die hat
er in seinem garten stehen high speed
haben wir jetzt auch noch die marmelade
hier vorne geklaut das heißt mit
lehrerinnen wir selbstverständlich auch
zu unserer wundervoll aussehenden
picknickdecke und ich glaube wir
brauchen jetzt nur noch die thermoskanne
das radio und den korb ok ich besorgt
die sachen mal eben ganz schnell
2000 jahre später
[Musik]
2000 jahre später h endlich das hat so
lange gedauert gerade
allerdings würde ich an der stelle das
heute wird jetzt auch beenden meine
damen und herren und zwar haben wir alle
challenges geschafft bis aufbringen den
gerne dazu seinen sohn zu tragen und
macht den gärtnern asphalt für diese
beiden challenges tipps und tricks habt
könnt ihr mir das gerne und in die
kommentare schreiben und schreibt mir
zudem auch gern einen namensvorschlag
für die ganz unten in die kommentare und
in der nächsten folge die ich dann in
einer woche hochladen werde werde ich
dann euch den namen verraten und die
nächsten challenges machen und
vielleicht hätten wir noch mehr von der
welt entdecken können habt ihr doch auch
bock darauf verlassen einen daumen hoch
unter dem video das schaffen wir 50.000
likes auf jeden fall mega krassen wird
mir zeigen er feiert das projekt
abonniert zudem gern meinen kanal
unternehmen video also klickt auf diesen
knopf ist es kostenlos und dem verpasst
das nächste video nicht mehr und ich
sehe halt immer dass so viele leute
meine videos schauen aber nicht abonnent
sind so 46,7 prozent hab ich glaube ich
gelesen schauen meine videos aber sind
nicht so hey ihr verpasst keine videos
mehr ist kostenlos und das letzte wort
hat jetzt die ganz
[Musik]